et sur le front en parallèle l'armée
ukrainienne a profité ce week-end de
cette rébellion de Wagner pour regagner
un tout petit peu de terrain à barmut
notamment mais l'armée ukrainienne
précise que Moscou n'a clairement pas
l'intention d'abandonner ses positions à
qui on retrouve notre correspondant du
livre crack
l'état major ukrainien dans son rapport
matinal aujourd'hui dit avoir repoussé
un certain nombre d'attaques russes donc
il est un peu l'effet miroir comme c'est
souvent le cas les Ukrainiens disent
qu'ils continuent par ailleurs leurs
opérations offensives maintenant c'est
pas uniquement dans le sud sur le front
de la région des abrisa et la partie
sud-ouest et la région de donuts mais
aussi à l'est à côté de bac mouth c'est
là qu'ils disent avoir avancé entre 600
mètres et 1 km donc des avancées très
modestes mais ils disent les Ukrainiens
que les opérations continuent aussi
qu'il s'agit d'une phase préparatoire en
ce moment de la contre-offensive c'est
ce que dit olexiesse nikov le dernier
interview en date un haut placé
ukrainien qui insiste sur le fait que il
s'agit en ce moment d'opération
préparatoire il y a des rumeurs il y a
même une vidéo ou peut-être d'autres
aussi j'ai vu une vidéo
gérant que les Ukrainiens auraient
franchi le fleuve niep
à Herson dans la ville de Herson donc
l'endroit qui était jusqu'à récemment
inondé mais les eaux maintenant descendu
mais le commandement pour l'armée
ukrainienne dans le sud du pays d'ici
c'est uniquement des rumeurs nous
n'avons rien dit et c'est probable à mon
sens qu'il ne s'agit pas vraiment d'une
tentative de traverser le tenir établir
des positions de l'autre côté mais
plutôt encore envolé dans cette bataille
qui a lieu à côté des Herson avec
beaucoup de frappe russe qui
de manière presque quotidienne
malheureusement tu des civils Ukrainiens
dans la région dans la région d'erson et
dans la ville derrière son aussi